Jay Pharoah is in the seat the actor
comedian he's in a new show
yes sir white famous white famous on
Showtime and
it premieres or know it you can see it
on Sunday nights at 10:30 Eastern and
Pacific it's called white famous based
on Jamie Foxx's life loosely based
loosely based on yes yes yes but yes I
am floyd mone and yeah the story so it's
a it's a show about a young black comic
who's trying to cross over into the
industry without selling his soul and he
really he could care less about fame he
just wants to he just really wants to
just be a funny dude like do stand-up
and all of that but you know he's
getting thrust into the industry world
and getting thrown in a mad weird
situation I mean there's definitely some
ball sweat which that was that was a
weird scene but how how are you sold how
you pitched this Jamie Foxx pitches it
to yeah it was you know I had got the I
I got the I got the pilot you know I was
reading because I was reading the script
I figure out what to do you know to you
know push my career for it and this came
through and I was like oh yeah I know
this story and you know I just connected
with the material immediately and went
in there in audition and got it but you
don't you're not imitating Jamie Farr no
oh no it's not me just have me doing
impression yeah like it's actually me
being like I'm being the character it's
not me being coming out like now I want
to talk about what the fizzle with the
Phase II it's not me doing that even
though as some of the outtakes I do do a
Jamie Foxx impression however it'll
never make it into the show but man
Jamie is Jamie's a fun dude man is he
easy to imitate um he was you know Jamie
was one of my Jamie is let me just
answer your question then yes yes for me
it is a lot of people not trying to
sound cocky just you know I know that I
kind of take another impression and kind
of like mix another one and to come up
with his voice it's kind of crazy it's
like it's like half a j.b smoove and all
because you know Jamie's new play what's
up fool
hey don't fool with him haha so if you
take that and like you switch it and you
put like a little bit of um you take it
and you make of my R and B ish like
you'll get Jamie Foxx and take the Lisp
out there's Jamie Foxx like for instance
what's up how you doing fool all right
no switches Jenny father
what's up fool how you doing fool you
see the difference yes you took I took
out the Lisp and I put the arm B swag to
it you know I mean a little more nasally
to a little more nasally you know so
yeah it's it's not you know thank God
can you describe no I don't know if you
can the scene with Jamie Foxx
in the trailer yeah I can describe but I
know but can you do it PG I can do it PG
okay I mean angle B is fun I saw this
scene with you know that Showtime scene
with Jay Pharoah and Jamie Foxx and I go
what he goes yep I don't know we're
having him on I don't think we can talk
about that team here's the thing here's
the thing okay and uh this scene is wild
but there is a dream sequence where I
it's a it's kind of uh let me see here
can I put this it's kind of a trance a
transgender situation boy well I don't
have something okay you know you're
missing I'm missing something okay I'm
missing my tools you're neutered yes
you're a guy you more than Newton your
guilt I am I am Wang lists wingless I
don't have I don't have you forget to
test these that that's okay that's gone
but the the tool Wow the moneymaker is
their aesthetics involved in it was it
was like with video editing and they had
they had me put on some drone and they
digitally took my penis digit how do you
explain that to me how do you explain
that to your mom mom is still there
I'm not gonna prove it to you you know
cuz all you know we ain't from West
Virginia but you know I don't know how I
don't know how they do when you listen
to how do you know when somebody is not
in your wheelhouse
to impersonate uh you know what I don't
even I don't even know if that's a if
that's a question because if I can't if
I if I can't get a voice I will sit
there and I will do it until I can do it
what's the longest you ever took before
you said I got the voice three years and
who Henzell why did it take so long
because then our swags are different and
you know my balls will appear you know
they look too hot yeah they weren't they
weren't down here young I was too young
okay now as a you know now I can I can
get into it it's not hard but do you try
to do like the scene from training day
uh-huh I mean you try it when you do
Denzel huh is it just Denzel in normal
conversation or you trying to do a movie
sing it's just it's just Denzel just
talking now if you if you ask Denzel he
said um yeah well you know the kids good
you know he's doing uh you know he does
training day it was training day Denzel
so I'm trying to figure out where he's
gonna go with it but uh you know he's
good he's a good man he's the kid is
funny I like the kid huh okay hi my man
hey you know it's funny too man because
when I do Denzel all of the older ladies
like they'd you know they like that yeah
this is this uh this splash that's all
i'ma say yeah splash like they like it a
lot yeah you know ever since he see me
doing doing the impression of him he has
tried his hardest not to do that lip
over buddy he has tried his heart is not
to do it like he's fighting it is the
face of a man struggling to not be
himself that's what it is right he's
struggling not to do that lip thing as
you know you do hmm
but you there's Chris Rock is he you do
Chris Rock you start with the hand yeah
it's just Chris
you don't even have to do any words and
I know who your in person come to your
show I've never seen any girls like well
I mean there's girls on the wall but she
can't screw them you know I'm trying to
get in there
he always looks like this alike that
he's staring at and it's like really
bright and it's you don't move your
mouth like the black Nutcracker he looks
like a nutcracker luckily because this
is perfect like his face
you know the artistry and that picture
is amazing I love that guy shout out to
him one of my idols but does she try to
change his mannerisms based on oh he is
surprisingly he came up to me he says I
love you impression I think it's good
you know as he's talking I'm just seeing
Sebastian from Little Mermaid he needs
to do a movie they need to do a movie at
a Joe's Crab Shack and he needs to play
like the crab that's that escaped so he
has his crab hits the crab hands it's
the hands of crabby with no patties in
them
does mr. Krabs from Sponge Bob is there
a piece of memorabilia that you would
want from a movie or TV show the piece
of memorabilia I want from a movie or TV
show I have to repeat the question
because I had a tedious somewhat spend
some time there thinking about it okay
you see here I want I want I want the
helmet from the witch-king of Angmar
from Lord of the Rings yeah McLovin
that's in your wheelhouse isn't it yeah
man I'll bid against you in an auction
that
awesome wait wait you will loser I am
the biggest Lord of the Rings fan and I
do not care I love it I used to be able
to recite the two towers all three hours
of the movie I loved it now don't ask me
if I could if I read the books cuz no
but I have watched the movie and I am
hooked I am a big Lord of the Rings fan
I wish I could have been wanted I guess
there was no black people right you
noticed that there was no black I guess
they were two orcs I guess you know how
that those would in words J Tyler Perry
presents Lord of the Rings how about
that no that wouldn't work no Madea
[Laughter]
get away from this town y'all need to
get away before this ring it's easy we
just drop it inside the volcano then
everybody go home are you are you a nerd
huh
you nerd and secretly everybody's I feel
like everybody's a nerd of something
yeah I mean that's everybody has their
thing
yeah but not Lord of the revered Lord of
the Ring you've never seen no no I got
other things to do do you watch Game of
Thrones no great but Lord of the Ring we
have nothing to talk about we had
nothing in common listen we do we did a
movie together it's true we did we did a
movie together did it come out I don't
know if it was an animated movie yeah
and Jay and I were stuck in this sound
room they talked and and it felt like at
times we were stuck there yeah we had to
we had to come up with the commentary
and go you know back and forth it was a
soccer match yeah and he was my analyst
there mm-hmm but you were playing you
then weren't you
I was playing now is I mean I was a
sports announcer yeah was it it was an
announcer you know I mean it was maybe
you weren't Steven Naismith no that
wasn't like Steven Naismith no no that
didn't happen no dan Patrick but you
have to understand you have to
understand the very breakdown of a movie
and how long it takes I shot a movie in
2012 that didn't come out to 2016 it was
blasphemous it was blasphemous in
dubious incredulous and suspicious in
conspicuity it was also it was awful to
dr. louis vuitton why would you say damn
somali what do you have is it called the
voice from underdogs yes yes it came out
and did it did short run yeah yeah we
didn't we didn't see it it was it was if
you want to know what it was it was
those part you know that company that
put yeah yeah you shouldn't talk about
yeah right we we look everybody got
silent no look everybody's like I don't
let's talk about that yeah Harvey
Weinstein yeah it was The Weinstein
Company yeah yep yeah we did it
you know you got the show on Showtime
yes sir and you also are gonna play
Richard Pryor
maybe we'll see what happens come on -
is that off wait we're not allowed to
bring that up I mean I mean look it's
it's it's it's up there could you it's
been talked about okay all right so
there's a chance that you're up for a
movie where you play Richard Pryor
it's definitely a chance oh I'm up for a
movie I play Richard Pryor and Pam Grier
and Pam Grier is biopic yes there's
there's there's a chance I love Pam
Grier oh I do too I did I met her we did
we both did zombies in space land like
we're both in the video game and I met
her she still looks great yeah she's oh
she's like she's like I'm vegan that's
how I do it like you know she's a little
she said you know she got better she was
sick she started she switched to be she
switched being a vegan and now she'll be
here for the next 200 years that's what
it is
grown man know grow men know you feel
like anybody a vegan in here but then
Seaton usually be used to be yeah you
know I'm glad you grew up grown man you
know chrome and vegans you're not a
vegan right nah man man I need protein I
need protein with legs I came I want
protein with legs that's what we need
you know I just want to do something fun
like right up on a vegan grown man vegan
and smack him in the face with a steak
Wow
from roof Chris and be like roof Chris
[ __ ] Wow I'll be so fun Wow all right
now when you see folks that do switch to
be a vegan and there's nothing wrong
with it if you've chosen its lifestyle
some people are sick some people need
this but you switch to him some people
switch to being a vegan for a weight
reasons and they're still fat you'd be
like hot didn't work do you do that no I
don't do that's what I do
feels feels great well we used to go to
the bar and we would order burgers and
wings and Seaton would be he'd have a
salad oh you know rabbit food we would
do it like slow motion where we would
bite the burger just to let it like
dripping down her to fan let it blow
blow in through your hair yeah you
didn't so really guys how long did this
how long did you how long were you you a
[ __ ] how long were you
mmm let's say I'm 39 now so I'm not
saying you're not yeah but he had a
couple of beers at a ballgame and then
went outside and then didn't you have a
I went to Fenway you had Fenway you had
had Yankees Red Sox and got outside and
there was a sausage and peppers truck
you get a couple of pops brought you
back oh man
look man like I said respect for
everybody who does it I'm just these are
just jokes yeah it's your comedian yeah
which is what is it joking around fun
and having a good time
can people see you studying them like
when you talk to somebody you know if
you're if you would make me nervous if I
was an actor or a musician where we're
talking and I'd feel like you're not
listening to what I'm saying but
listening how I said do do people feel
me doing that um I'm gonna tell you
Beyonce was scared to say anything
around me she told me she was like
what'd she say she goes I don't want to
say anything around you because I want
you person ate me just like you know
without fake jay-z hilarious could you
forward if you called if I called and
you fool her the ever Jay I didn't know
where we were going I was like hey dude
could I fool her if I caught her as I
think so really
I'm like yeah Mimi had to meet me at the
Sofitel want to do something I'm
different I want to be a naughty little
hole you know I actually used that one
time Hova yo i'ma tell this story one
time one time me and me and me and my ex
we were in act and you know I didn't
want to you know end it yeah and I was I
was old
had me against the ropes like she had me
against ropes and I was like oh god what
I need to do and like all of a sudden
all of a sudden I'm about to I'm about
to get kayoed right she I love these
colorful ways yeah okay I'm about to get
Kay out and then that just go now one
time another time Dan yes J since were
since we're being honest and you're my
friend I could tell you about this ah
there was uh there was a there was a
lady and she was you know she was older
than me
probably by like six years whatever all
right so yeah we uh were we're under the
influence right and I was uh we were in
the act again and I just started doing
Richard Pryor and she laughed like I
don't know what but I wasn't against the
ropes at this point did she know she
always do a rich surprised she's older
of course you know yeah you like this
[Laughter]
listen no cuz I've cursed all I'm in
front of the nice white folks I've
cursed online and I'm sorry I apologize
but I thought that the a word was you
can say it on FX shoe you can say that s
word or FX so no it's not effects but if
you what type of world do we live in
what a man cannot say as
the man is keeping us down J that's
what's happened the man is keeping you
will you meet a man's keeping you down
Smith could probably say that Shannon
Sharpe could say that but I think that's
that rule is omitted at the Dan Patrick
show fritzy would you do your shannon
sharpe very good important to me and
what I want to do is 298 oh I know why
because I've been talking like this ever
since 18 I've been talking like yo
Shannon is gonna see me one day and he's
gonna whoop my ass
he's Jay Ferrel the show is white famous
it's on Showtime
Sundays at 10:30 Eastern specific thanks
again for coming thanks on the success
and you get to do that Richard Pryor
movie then good for you I will be
amazing that would be nice that but
funny I just slipped the impression in
there no I know I like this it almost
feels like you've been working on almost
four more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]